popular CBS show FBI Most Wanted returns
tonight for its fourth season The
Fugitive task force is back in Action to
investigate crime and there to lead them
is detective Remy Scott who's played by
Dylan McDermott I caught up with a Remy
yeah I mean I think this season is going
to be jam-packed we have 22 Episodes of
more crime than you could ever desire
and we have a team in place that's going
to bring down a lot of bad guys but
tonight in particular you're going to
see Grandma go undercover for the first
time and I hope it's many times but
tonight is the first time we see him go
undercover as a biker and you get to see
him in some very very dangerous
situations you see some personal stories
uh you see Barnes come back so tonight I
think it's a very special episode and
season four premiere couldn't be more
exciting
well you've taken on so many different
roles throughout your career from Comedy
Drama Action a little bit of everything
what Drew you to this role of of Remy
and how do you kind of like get into
character
yeah I mean uh good question I was doing
Law and Order organized crime uh for a
couple of Seasons I have been playing
some bad guys for a while and I felt it
was time to play a good guy again well
and speaking of different roles I gotta
say we're approaching the holidays in
just a few months we're gonna see you on
our screen again and one of my favorite
movies Miracle on 34th Street I gotta
ask because I'm such a sucker for it
please just tell me that's one of your
favorite roles and favorite movies
because it's just so good oh man I I
mean what a miraculous picture
um and you know Sir Richard Attenborough
working with him as Santa Claus was one
of the highlights of my career it was a
great great cast Laura Wilson
um and John Hughes the late John Hughes
produced and wrote that movie so you
know it was in the 90s as a matter of
fact we took the movie to England and I
got to meet the queen
uh uh for the premiere of Miracle on
34th Street many many moons ago oh my
gosh what a great story and how special
of a moment I'm sure for you and to kind
of reminisce on now given everything
that's happened but that makes me happy
to hear because that's just one of those
movies you can't help but smile when you
watch
you know we're local here in Vegas I
just gotta ask do you enjoy coming to
visit our city and what do you love
about it craps is my weakness I I love
coming to Vegas and playing craps the
shows the food the people I mean it's
just you know one of the most fun places
on the planet the final wrap up here
again tonight we have the season
premiere of FBI Most Wanted what are you
most excited for people to see or what
are you kind of helping people take away
from this season last season I came for
the last six episodes so this is my
first full season so I'm really excited
for people to see me in 22 Episodes uh
different stories different crimes each
week me leading the team
um this is a really satisfying night of
Television so please come bring your
friends and watch FBI Most Wanted
well FBI Most Wanted season four
premiere is happening tonight right here
on channel 8. he's been